[Music]
we've gotten a few unofficial looks at
the Nintendo switches main menu this
month and now it seems that the Mario
company has confirmed what it'll look
like and launch I'm Matt and this
gamespot news update is switching things
up Nintendo's UK website features an
image of the switch displaying its main
menu the site also describes what the
icons below your games are the first is
news the second is the eShop and the
third is a screenshot album where you
can edit screenshots and post them to
social media sites the page also has
images that highlight the various
elements of the switch dock and
accessories you can check them all out
for yourself on gamespot com the switch
is set to launch on March third
pre-orders for the console of Seoul know
that many retailers and it's accessories
aren't sticking around either some
places may still have some pre orders in
stock but with supply selling out almost
immediately it doesn't look like they'll
last for long we'll keep you updated on
when switch products become available so
for that and much more from the world of
video games stay tuned to GameSpot's
you